good to see you man been a while
uh yeah it might have been the last
narcos junket is that what it was yeah
it might have been i'm surprised they
let me talk to you again after that i'm
joking
i was about to say i don't remember it
being bad i'm joking listen uh i
finished the new season yesterday i just
want to say congrats i really enjoyed it
uh really enjoyed that ending um that's
all i have i'll see you guys later have
a great
when you signed on did you know
how ultimately how involved walt was
going to be in this series or was it
sort of like you were signing on for one
season um
that's a great question i
i i
they had come to me for a well i don't i
don't have time for that um
i did know that i was gonna be uh
the
lead of the dea in season two of mexico
and then
and um season two of mexico and then on
the third season i wasn't sure if they
were going to bring me back or not and
so you know knowing that you know they
sort of pushed walt's storyline a little
bit further down the road and also gave
them a little bit more closure with
something that i was excited about
uh louise you did a great job this
season totally disappeared into this
role
really went for it when you signed on um
did you what they approached you did
they did you have any idea ultimately of
your arc or was it sort of like narcos
yeah just where do i sign oh yeah it was
like that i was like narcos yes i mean
and then i had a meeting with the
producers and they met me and they
offered me the role and they saw me and
one hour after that they called my agent
and they were like no he's not he can't
play the part he's too skinny
and i was like what and uh and then i
they asked me to gain uh like 25 pounds
or something and
that's it
yeah when i when i watch the season i'm
like this is not the guy that i
recognize i can't this isn't no and then
i you know obviously was like oh [ __ ]
this is the guy he just yeah yeah it was
a lot of fun because i was like yeah
okay i'm gonna
put all this weight for six months and
that that's gonna be fine and then kobe
happened
and i stayed without weight for a year
and a half
yeah yeah enjoy that scoot enjoy it
i didn't think about that yeah yeah it
took me a year to lost it
yeah first of all i can't imagine that
because that's also i can't imagine that
that really has to [ __ ] with you you i'm
sure yeah
yeah it does it does it's horrible i
will never do it again but but i mean it
was it was perfect for this role i mean
my dad was a doctor working in the
police in mexico in the 90s and um i i
grew up watching him and watching his
friends and the policemen and uh i mean
it was the only way to play that role
you know like with that uh commitment
and putting all putting all all this
weight and i'm just i'm not talking
about just the physical weight you like
the weight
of of asking himself all the time
what the hell is integrity you know in a
place like juarez in the 90s so um for
me it was a fascinating experience and
i'm really grateful to be able to to
tell this story which is for me the
biggest
issue in my country is still today you
know like 10 women get killed every day
in mexico
right now and that started in the 90s in
siddha juarez because of the rise of of
violence and drug trafficking in in the
in the north of the country so
it's it's really painful but i think
it's also very necessary to put it out
there
yeah both of you guys what's interesting
about both of your characters is you're
both obsessed you're both playing people
obsessed and i'm just curious how does
that um i guess how is that as an actor
to do that for months on end to stay in
that headspace is it easy to sort of get
home from set and shut that off or to
sort of stay with you a little bit
well i'm obsessed with everything all
the time so it's really easy to relate
to them
yeah i feel i i feel the same way i have
an obsessive uh personality as well um
uh but in regards to like sort of
sticking with it i didn't have to stick
with the
the belly but uh you know
when you're working it when you're
working in mexico you know a lot of
these things that we're talking about
are still very um
you know apparent and and
happening so
you
you stay in it because you're you're not
surrounded by it but you are when you go
on location to some of the places that
you kind of feel that
you you kind of still feel that
uh for both of you guys um what have you
been telling friends and family about
season three like how have you been
saying it to them what do you want to
tease
um
it's an exciting
season with uh one of my favorite things
about the narcos um franchise is the way
that they bring back in other characters
that we've seen before
and they feel like they do a really
fascinating job with that and one of the
exciting things about this season is to
sort of see what happens when the boss
or
the ceo of a massive company
goes under
and the fight and the struggle for who's
going to be the next leader
and what the repercussions are of that
is something that will unfold and and
and that the viewer will be able to
watch
and it's
exciting and very like the show's entire
history the history of the show is very
very real and and accurate yeah for me
it's it's been fascinating to tell my
friends like
you remember our childhood
now you're gonna understand what really
happened you know because we we grew up
with all these news about the christine
about the cardinal
campo about colossia and about all these
things and of course now we know
you know like what really happened but
when you see it on the show you
understand
how incredibly complex this problem is
and how
in a way we are all part of this problem
you know like corruption
uh
like living in mexico we are all part of
that corruption when a officer gives you
a ticket and you give him money to stay
away of the ticket but at the same time
in new york if you're having cocaine or
whatever you have that blood in your
hands you know and that
like understanding that level of
complexity i think it's it's fascinating
to watch and i think that's one of the
reasons uh narcos has so many fans
around the world you know because it's
so incredibly raw and real
uh i have a different perspective on the
drug the drug war after watching all the
seasons of this series do you guys have
a different perspective on the drug war
after being involved in the making of
the show
oh yeah 100
100
um i i i mean i sort of might
after doing the show for sure but i did
a film in mexico like
20's 12 years ago
and it wasn't based on the drug
trafficking but just being down there
and seeing the effects of it
changed my
perception of the drug world and the
cartels 12 years ago and doing this show
only helped me to understand it even
more
um i got to stop there they're going to
kick me out i'm just going to say for
everyone who's never seen halton catch
fire now is the perfect time
and uh i [ __ ] loved that show and
seriously thank you so much guys for a
great season and talking to me today
awesome thank you thank you so much for
taking the time
you